aps le mans que nous ne sommes pas
compris nous ne sommes pas entendus par
ce gouvernement
malgré toutes les demandes que nous
avions que nous avons fait
j'en veux pour preuve courrier que j'ai
fait que j'ai fait au ministre de
l'intérieur en juin dernier enjeu
dernier donc j'ai reçu sa réponse fin
juillet où je l'interpellé justement sur
la montée en charge de la sécurité sur
le territoire le nombre de personnes
décédées le nombre de personnes tuées
sur le territoire l'on ne parle pas
seulement du lamenter on parle sur
l'ensemble du territoire
aujourd'hui voilà donc je coince à voir
aujourd'hui que nous avons nous
parlementaires une j'envie 10 ou que
nous avons un droit d'entrée hommiste de
au ministère de l'intérieur de façon à
nous faire entendre parce que trop c'est
trop
sur notre territoire alors comme vous
êtes